welcome to this video playing fish puppy
here with black from the US and at least
I've got 2,100 again which school does
not feel very good but it was below that
okay so we get there get a color color
system here call azucar thought now it's
not a zoo controlled he hasn't played be
three but ok um he and 95 it's normally
the way to play that I'm gonna put
something on the default
yeah white wants to play see form or if
or at at some point not sure maybe try
to make see for a bit more difficult
okay if he goes yeah I was thinking
about that what should I do now is there
some other move then retreat hang out I
guess not okay so what now maybe back to
e7 this keeps an eye on the a3 porn Adam
and it allows to recapture with the
Queen and if he decides to take he
indeed decides to take and surprising
gather isolated porn is not not a
problem at all i can i can even play
Bishop b5 am just not even it's the
normal move ready yeah come on it sir
let's play the normal why not
yeah for the isolated corner have firm I
have two bishops and negative position
and it's it's quite favorable for me
that I have this the sum a 5v5 inserted
this gives me some useful squares on the
queenside especially c5 like rook to c5
vette at some point can be very useful
okay um I cannot exchange everything off
as d 4 is under such pressure just
improving a bit here okay here loss
allows bishop age three rook do one can
take deform play Queen f3 so that's
probably not leading to much I wonder if
I should do that maybe I can play this
actually with Roxy five being yeah I
know I can play rook c5 because of this
this pinning situation he cannot take c5
takes be takes and then I'm grinning
it's night so I actually managed to
double on the C file it's quite nice to
achieve
now I'm threatening to take a couple of
times on c1 and then grab the power on
deform it's not easy to prevent even now
you cannot take because of B takes and
I'm winning the night so at the end team
gives up the C file okay
can i play can i play rook c3 or yeah
roots III is good I think idea is to
take and then rooks it to getting on the
second rank maybe you can play Knight f3
it's a bit of a sick move I cali I kev
ruki three okay i have rookie three ruki
395 rookie five rogue d5 a very sick
line
and let's let's consider this year for a
moment look III 9595 rookie five roop d5
that's really not working amazing
and take with the Queen f e Queen takes
you three Fisher the fire from it's very
close to working time morning it's a
shame if I really is a shame sometimes
it's kind of miracle move that it saves
saves the other side
now I'm very much down on the clock
the idea I don't don't have anything
really don't it's not a problem I think
but it it was it was quite clearly a
good position before okay this is again
good for black I get in deform and then
i have the far better endgame his pawns
our own light squares we should be three
as the point check
okay i get i get i get a pass on the
edge file and now the queenside is
falling apart yeah it was lost in any
case because of the far superior black
activity quite resigned we have it still
weird how could he how was snider three
possible maybe I'm just as usual
overlooking some tactic that would have
won at okay rook to e3 Bishop f5 a
stronger I am gay I am with this direct
idea this is very strong actually poo
it's very strong if he goes here I can
just take here then rooks e2 and
something like this is also very nice
nice he's overloaded him the the whole
structures overloaded and here this is
ya rookies 3 was working so how was it
working i didn't i didn't understand
yeah i was calculating this but I
thought he can take and I wasn't sure I
wasn't sure okay this is the point hmm
okay my problem was I saw this move and
I wasn't sure that Bishop f5 is doing
anything great yeah this is this is
defending but I have this length and
Roxy to this is the big point
and this wins now okay then this was
possible yeah we yeah this is his check
winning the Queen okay okay I didn't see
that but ok this this keeps an advantage
it seems here I had Lucas e2 okay yeah
but okay the good the good news is that
this end game isn't isn't any problem
really I shouldn't win it but it's also
not a problem and in fact he fall into
this trap here that Luke see one Luke
see one is just losing him I don't think
that white can hold this the combination
of my better king and end the bed porn
structure in relation to the bishop
should should win it yes the computer
stock crushes on minus one which is
probably fair assessment okay I mean not
a fair assessment that's wrong i mean
the computer is not giving minus two or
three like a total winner somewhat it's
clear that black is substantially better
i can now it's getting getting higher
even okay thanks for watching